the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about two
yet unseen seats of two Great Houses the
strongholds that we are going to see in
the upcoming season the first one that
we are going to see in season seven is
said to be among the most beautiful
castles in the Seven Kingdoms it's
situated on a broad symmetrically shaped
Hill is known for its famous briar maze
labyrinth of beautifully maintained
hedges displays between the outermost
and middle balls and serves two
important purposes as entertainment for
the castles inhabitants and as
deterrence against enemies since an
invader that would manage to penetrate
the other wall would have a hard time
finding their way throughout the complex
growth of thorns the same castle is
known for its beautiful complex of
towers courtyards greenery fountains and
for its places of worship while outside
its walls metals and fields of flowers
can be seen in every direction indeed by
any chance you haven't figured out about
which stronghold I'm talking about it's
the seat of house Tyrell and the
regional capital the reach its
Highgarden this famous stronghold beside
being noted for its gardens also
contains the square towers that date
from the Age of Heroes while newer
towers are taller and round this set of
house Tyrell that we're going to see in
the upcoming season will be portrayed by
Amador
del Rio Kastle that was built in eight
century and was restored a few times
throughout history this castle will
probably have an appearance in three
episodes as three directors accompanied
with show runners were preparing castle
for filming once the leaked photos
confirmed that we are about to see this
beautiful stronghold we all surely
didn't expect battle taking place inside
its walls
even though League plot stated it but as
time was passing as the casting for
extras took place with request fourteen
people in good physical condition with
military experience to play soldiers and
with a Lannister flag that was seen
flying on this same castle that will
represent Highgarden battle it in its
Falls quickly became a certain event of
season 7 as I've already brought you a
video four months ago in which I
provided you all informations about a
battle and the death of a major
characters that will happen in
Highgarden
I will not talk that much about it in
this video but in a case you're not cut
out with spoilers and
in case you didn't watch my previous
videos I'm going to repeat a few edits
point confirm notes about an event that
will take place inside Highgarden Searcy
who should be proclaimed as the math
queen destroy the only strong Lannisters
ally which means that she will have to
make a new alliances and beside your own
Greyjoy the tourists are going to be a
Lannisters new allies which at first
sounds extremely surprising as house
Tarly of horn Hill is among the houses
that swear fealty to house Tyrell of
Highgarden but a fact is dead ahead of
house Tarly Randall has always been
loyal towards Lord paramount of the
reach but has always despised her well
women now that all male Tyrells are
killed Olenna Tyrell is left as the sole
member and ruler house Tyrell
accompanied with the fact that randyll
Tarly has always despised her well women
DISA lines between the Lannisters and
the tarly's after all is not that
surprising the result of this same
alliance is going to be Jaime Lannister
leaning Leinster army along with Randall
and deacon Tarly leading their Tarly
army they're going to march on
Highgarden and also from leaked photos
they've seen the outcome of that battle
which will result the Jaime's and
Randall's victory that is not surprising
at all Jaime and Randall will have
numbers they work numbered Tyrell
soldiers and both of them have a lot of
military experience especially randyll
Tarly who is known as one of the best
battle commanders in the Seven Kingdoms
if you're wondering were they going to
attack Highgarden the answer is pretty
simple so let's just put it this way
beside the most important purpose beside
destroying their enemy and decreasing
Daenerys his strength by conquering
Highgarden
Cersei will also conquer important
crossroads as Highgarden lies on the
banks of the river Mandor in this video
she Road means the Rose Road and is a
major passage linking Old Town and
King's Landing and beside those two
facts Highgarden also has rich fields
and was provisioning food to the capital
something the Lannisters lost at killing
almost every member of house Tyrell in
the third season Margaery perhaps even
four share of this assault in Highgarden
as your mine is her shield importance of
house Tyrell support in the war as the
reach provided food to the capital while
this March and the assault in Highgarden
are confirmed by leaked photos by leaked
plot Jaime will also confront Olenna
Tyrell while is at Highgarden according
to leaked plot Lady Olenna will admit to
Jaime everything
about how she and Littlefinger poison
Joffrey which will and the Jamie
alarming Elena to drink poison and kill
herself before getting captured for all
of you that are wondering why would the
Len admit to Jamie that she killed his
firstborn son the answer is actually
pretty simple if you still remember a
conversation between lady Elena and
Petyr Baelish which happened in seven
episode of season five a conversation in
which the Queen of thorns threatened
Littlefinger and said I promised the
Lord Baelish that our fates are joined
together be murdered the king if my
house should fall I will have nothing to
hide
at a moment in with Jamie and Randall
conquer Highgarden Lady Olenna will be
aware that her life is over that she can
either kill herself or become a hostage
which would also result in her death
eventually Lady Olenna aware that her
fate is sealed at a moment in me Jamie
is going to confront her at Highgarden
will admits everything to Jamie because
as she said herself she has nothing to
hide once her house falls as we know her
house had fallen supported by a fact
that lady Elena will be aware that she's
going to die one way or another lady
Elena will certainly admit to Jamie
everything since that's something what
Elena would do meaning that the leaf
plot seems to fit flawlessly with the
mind awfully natural it sadly makes like
plot once again being pure truth as many
times since it's been leaked all of
these that I mentioned in the last
minute or two was only a few most
important notes about the battle and the
day that is going to happen inside
Highgarden walls everything that you
have already been introduced with in my
previous videos after they conquered
Highgarden Jamie Randall with their
armies will march back home it carriages
full of goods loaded from Highgarden
while they're heading home the nurses
army will take Jameson Reynolds army and
take an opportunity to fight them on the
open field and to venture a lie which is
confirmed by Lee photos as well this
huge battle will start with the tracking
ambush but during the battle the nurse
will also be riding dragon which a lot
of smoke and burnt carriages are
confirming this battle will end with a
lot of casualties for both sides as we
can see a lot of that man on the ground
but it's going to be the nurses victory
however during this battle Randall and
the contrarily are going to be captured
Val bran will save Jamie from almost get
killed whereupon they're going to escape
and go to the second stronghold that
we're going to see for the very first
time in the upcoming season this
stronghold is located on the western
coast of Westeros on a rocky promontory
overlooking the sunset sea this castle
is built into a natural rock formation
it's curved out of great stone hill
colossal rock beside the sunset sea and
its base contains large sea carved
caverns while Highgarden is among the
most beautiful castles in the Seven
Kingdoms this castle is among the most
formidable and well defended castles in
Westeros and has been measured that
three times the height of the wall of
high tower of old town as you probably
guessed by now I'm talking about the
capital of the westerland's about the
ancestral stronghold of House Lannister
and because of all these specifications
the Casterly Rock also known as The Rock
will be an ideal shelter for Jaime and
Bronn even though they won't stay long
in the Casterly Rock still we are going
to see this famous seat of House
Lannister for the first time in the
books
Tyrion described the strength of
Casterly Rock through his thoughts as he
once thought stone I must be stoned I
must be Casterly Rock hard and unmovable
Casterly Rock will be represented by
chuka Castle as you could see a lot of
leaked photos from set at Trujillo
castle along with Jaime and Bronn and
swalls accompanied by hundreds of
Lannister soldiers the same soldiers the
Jaime will lead to the north after the
gold wedding the three according to a
theory of mine will witness in the end
of season 7 which is going to be similar
to the red wedding as I've already said
in this video I introduced you a little
bit more with two famous strongholds
that we are going to see for the first
time in the upcoming season but all
notes about events that are going to
take place inside those castles along
with the inn's ambush I have already
introduced you with a few months ago
brought here only to remind you about an
importance of appearance of already
mentioned strongholds in conclusion the
showrunners had the biggest budget to
spend in comparison with any season so
far
which along with the fact that the
upcoming season will contain only seven
episodes of usual ten in my opinion
spending money on providing a story at
unseen payment strongholds beside battle
scenes and scenes that will include
dragons and dire wolves is the best
possible way to spend it if you want
more details about
versus new alliances about Harley's
betrayal but Jamie's and Randall's
assault on Highgarden about Elena's
death or about Danny's ambush and
Jamie's escape to Casterly Rock or even
want more details about gold wedding
theory of mine feel free to check my
other videos in which I provided every
single detail about those events as in
this video included only the most
important highlights before I wrap up
this video let me remind you that a few
days ago I announced a new giveaway in
which you have a chance to win $50
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
participate in this giveaway is simply
to be subscribed liked this video and
leave a comment about this topic winner
of this giveaway will be announced in
the first video next week in the
following days you can expect to see
more videos about fates of characters in
season 7 as I want to include every main
character in my character fate series
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace